some pretty stark figures laid out today
as the Bank of England and the
government both look ahead to what life
could be like after brexit well I'm
joined now by the Labour MP Catherine
McKenna a former shadow Treasury
Minister a member of the Treasury select
committee Conservative MP androgen
Keynes who's a member of the brexit
Select Committee and the SMPS Treasury
spokesperson Alison feuless thank you
all very much indeed for being with us
some bright spark is noticed you're all
wearing your party well done very well
coordinated thank you very much now
Catherine McKenna let's come to you
first and we've seen these very dire
predictions is it project fear or is it
actually a sensible forecast well I
think it's project reality and the
Chancellor confirmed this morning quite
alarmingly that under any brexit
scenario we are going to be worse off as
a country and for many years to come
and I think it's the only time I can
think of and possibly anyone can think
of where the government's actively
pursuing a policy that is going to make
us and our constituents and our families
poorer and there are regions of the
country that are going to be affected
much harder than others and my region of
the Northeast being one of them Andrew
Jenkins the government has got this
wrong before they they predicted
Armageddon if we voted leave in the
first place and the economy seems to be
doing okay I completely agree with that
statement and also remember they they
failed to protect predict the financial
crash this is clearly just to mongering
by the Treasury in the Chancellor and I
for one have got more faith in Britain
and the British people and I think we
can't have another rerun of the
referendum the do mongering let's just
get on with the job what we got tested
you I was a few lists the prime minister
up in Scotland today selling her deal to
the public we all need to be a bit more
optimistic that we I think the
Chancellor has been completely honest
this morning that it is gonna be a
disaster regardless of which breaks that
scenario that they pick and all of this
will be particularly bad for Scotland my
constituents would see themselves being
1600 pounds per head worse off under
these scenarios
so there's nothing that the Prime
Minister can do to sell this deal in a
matter where she goes in Scotland
overwhelmingly sixty-two percent voted
to remain so she'll get a particularly
hard till in Scotland the promises
saying today that actually the deal is a
good one for Scotland free-trade area no
tariffs no fees Scotland's interests
have been taken into account
Scotland chests have been completely
ignored all the way through this process
the First Minister has been ignored and
the option that the SNP are put forward
as a compromise of staying within the
single market and the customs union
which is not as bad as Briggs and
certainly a good deal better than the
terrible deal she's proposing has been
completely ignored and it is a sensible
option that we're done sure get the
support of MPs across the house sorry I
think the big issue with the premise
that you make there though is that the
government cannot guarantee any of those
things this Agreement that we are being
asked to vote for that we know will make
our constituents poorer is actually an
agreement to leave the European Union in
terms of what the forward relationship
is going to be it's a very vague
declaration that has no legal binding
power whatsoever so we don't actually
know whether there will be this
frictionless trade we don't know whether
there will be all of it which is why all
the economic projections have to be so
variable because it has to forecast
every possible outcome that may come
once we vote through and I will not vote
to it through and this withdrawal
agreement that we're being presented
with so and it you know the this is a
blind brexit we're being asked to vote
completely blind on what the future will
look like yeah in any in any divorce
there's got to be compromise hasn't
there on both sides no one's ever happy
in a divorce that they've got everything
they want that's the situation here I
mean I think it should be more like you
accurately termed a remain agreement
actually but what I'm hearing from you
know two panelists you know with respect
and what we're hearing from the Treasury
really is just a rerun of the referendum
argument and people voted I'm a Democrat
you know I trust the British people so
we should just get on and deliver what
the British people voted for we
shouldn't be talking about this now we
should just be getting on and delivering
no but the problem is we're all debating
what we think the British people voted
for and Teresa may suggest that this
agreement is what the bush people voted
for Andrea doesn't think it's what the
British people voted for
nor does Alice Allison but the point is
how do we actually find out what it is
that the bishop people voted for we go
back and ask them we present this a deal
that the Theresa May has arrived at and
we ask the people whether they accept it
or not and the choice has to be do you
accept this brexit that has been
negotiated by the government or do you
want to stay on our current terms which
is remain in the European Union and
that's a clear choice and a clear
mandate that we can get from the budget
people well we can seek resume now in
Scotland today visiting a local business
alison Thewlis do you think that
people's votes is the solution out of
this I think it's a solution of this
certainly and as I said before Scotland
is perfectly clear that we voted to
remain I can see why the the prospectus
that Katherine puts forward is appealing
vo because there are all ranges of
reasons why people voted the way that
they dead people were believed various
different promises they were governed
whether they were written on the side of
the bus so and presented by people who
have no resigned all of these things
were put before the people and we don't
know exactly what people were expecting
out of this deal but they Sarah not
certainly were not voting to be worse
off at the end of the day and that is
exactly what's going to happen with this
deal well I trust of British people
let's not forget that the government at
the time you know my government spent 9
million pounds put in this project fear
leaflets through every household yet the
British people still voted for to leave
we must honor what the British people it
was you know the brexit campaign wasn't
without its project fear I there was it
you know the bus the famous three
hundred and fifty million for the NHS
we've got money going what we've seen
today from the economic projections is
that we will be poor under every brexit
scenario that's less money for our
hospitals less less money from Georgian
money probably not services you know
forecasts are not facts but how many
times have you know there's nothing
wrong I mean even Mervyn King is as said
we're better going for a hard brexit
than pursuing the PM's deal you know
that's the you know former given said
we'd be better off staying in the
European Union and going for this
withdrawal agreement because it
effectively as you said retains a lot of
the benefits of being in the European
Union but without actually having a sale
any of those rules and I think that's
what breaks our tears like Andrea find
very difficult to live with but also and
people who I speak to who wonder why are
we doing this at all well let me put
this question to you then on the 11th of
December the vote will take place in
Parliament do you think what has
happened today these dire predictions
are going to make any MPs think again
who were going to vote against Theresa
Mays deal who are now thinking well
actually maybe this argument pushes me
more towards voting with her I think a
lot of MPs have already made up their
minds how they're going to vote on this
issue and I don't think it will make a
huge big difference here but what is
absolutely clear is that the Prime
Minister's trying to present this as her
Deal or No Deal and that is a completely
false choice because I believe that
there are better deals that could be had
there is certainly a better option that
could be had the customs union in the
single market and as I said I think that
will have a majority throughout the
house so there needs to be an option
through this process but in peace to see
actually this is a false choice we want
neither of these things because both of
them are damaging and both of them are
not as good a sting within the EU both
agree absolutely I think from their
photo you know I think we do all agree
on that that this is a false prospectus
and I think we're being threatened
really with this idea of a No Deal that
would be catastrophic but also every
other Breck's adoption that's been
offered to us also makes us poorer so
you know as MPs were elected to act in
the national interest but with a
specific care for our constituents and
none of our constituents voted for us to
make them poorer or to make our families
poorer or indeed to make our children
pay the price for this decision for many
years to come I feel one believe in our
country and you know workers out there
our businesses that waiting them go back
and ask I'm so you should listen usually
get we have we we have not used our
strongest cards there's a 67 billion
pound trade deficit with the EU then he
does you know we shouldn't have promised
the 39 billion pound without seeing the
scope of the deal it has been a car
crash the last two years but the fact is
there is a better deal that we that we
could have yet we'll all disagree on
what that could be you said there is no
- deal they said there is nothing
because they've got everything they want
they've got everything they want we'll
be a real taker
whispers still be a subject to the ECJ
that they'll tell us how to make our
projects and and its makes it difficult
to do free trade deals with other
countries I think I know who you Dave
got what they want and it's not what the
British people okay so what's your
prediction then for if this vote is a it
goes against the primary so what's going
to happen next I don't think anybody can
really tell you what will happen next
after that I am that's for sure because
what the premaster has to take into
account is the will of the house on this
hard deal has if that comes to pass has
not been acceptable to the majority of
MPs and it's clear that from us here
today from other MPs within the house to
the DUP to everybody else it's just not
acceptable to anybody other than the the
most loyalist of loyal Tory backbenchers
and so I think we need to look at this
seriously we need to come up with an
option that satisfies the needs of our
constituents also satisfies the will of
of the House and to see that aim that we
see and then the single markets to see
that we see in the customs you mean it's
also the easiest way out of this for
everybody it will solve a lot of the
issues for Northern Ireland as well it
will continue to tell those still it has
treed and to to have the access that we
need to the EU it will stop it and
that's a red line you know we can talk
in hypotheticals and we can talk in you
know possible deals that may or may not
be available but you know the clock is
ticking on this and trees I may have
spent two years negotiating this deal
which is why I feel very strongly that
with the only way to actually know if
this is actually the will of the British
people is if we go back and ask them and
we have a brexit this is brexit it's
been presented to us and and as much as
whether you like it or you don't
it is a brexit deal and therefore it's
time to put it back to the bishop people
in the people's vote final thought the
only people who want a second referendum
is those who voted remain as a salt
losers vote and and I'll fight to ensure
that does not happen okay Catherine
McKenna Andrew Jenkins Alison fearless
thank you all very much indeed good see